Yle Areena.
Seitskyt kahdeksan prosenttia, mikä minun lasokelmieni mukaan tekee kuukaudesna peräti 9,36 euroa, joten kyllä nyt eräkeläiste ostovoima nousee, kun riippoo kohti jää vähän päälle kaksi euroa, kyllä tällä nyt mällätään, että kiitokset vaan päättäjille, oi moi.
Jälleen on aika todeta perinteisti eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tällä kertaa puolituntissa käsitellään ainakin luontoa, liikkumista ja sote teemoja. Monia muitakin aiheita on toki myös tarjolla.
Nyt on arpoa norialaista mitallistit, ja ehdotetaanpa kuntoilijoiden ladulle hiihtovahteakin. Nyt on työllisyyskatsauksen aika.
Nyt on työllisyyskatsauksen lisääntyminen keihtyy, niin ollaan paremman tien alussa.
Näin katsoman puolelta seuraan tätä työllisyys/työttömyystilannetta, ja huonolta on näyttänyt, mutta saattaa hyvinkin olla käännetta parempaan tulossa ennen seuraavaa huonoa vaihetta.
Nä hyvää sunnuntain jatkoa, kiitoksiaan.
Kiitos Maunolle Jyväskylään, kovin pitkälle ei maantieteellisesti siirrytä seuraavaksi, kun tieme vie Sysmään.
Luvassa on laajasti sanottuna luontoa ja liikkumista.
Minne moi.
Moimin.
Tulee ni kauheesti haukkuja.
Noi, tuli jo koiran kakka haukkuja tuossa, mikä oli mut ihan hyvä.
Keläkään ei voi sanoa yhtään mitään Suomessa.
Otetaan vähän isompi näkökulma.
Täs ku ku kuuntelee, että mitä hiihto laduilla.
Ni se aika hirvittävä, että kuudetaan ja ollaan ku Eurooppa omistajat siellä.
Muukamas koko ladu tunnetaan ja sinä meet väärään suuntaan ja sinä meet oikeeseen.
Sis aivan järjetentä.
Sis aivan naurettavaa.
Nää on yhteisiala, niinku laduja kaikki hiihtäjille.
Millä tää tilannetta voisi parantaa?
Sillä, että miettii omaa tunnetasoa ja myöskin mä oon miettinyt, että sinne pitäis loittaa hiihto vahtaja.
Hiihto vahtaja?
Kyllä, eli palkataan sinne hiihtämään sitten porukkaa ja sitten nää kettoisella kokoja alkousuutaan ja päätään. Niin tota, laiteta on ladu pois.
Eli jonkunlaisia järvestyvalvojia?
Juu, koska näitähän on nyttu tuolla jo rinti.
Aivan.
Niitähän on, joo. Siis näitähän on laitettu kato rinteisiin.
Joo, joo. Kiitoksia, Minna, tästä ehdotuksesta.
Hiihto vahtaja, kun on rinne vahtajat. Hei.
No, terve, terve, se on kakka sani kaheksan kolme päijät hämöestä, ku täällä langan päässä roikkuu.
Soittelen täältä koiran kanssa tenkkeilemästä, ni pahoittelut us vähän huohotan, mutta.
Tämmönen asia ku, nää kaupunkien nurmialueet, ni oon vähän huolissani, että miten ne kestää, noin niinku ravinteiden puolesta.
Tä säidän ääriolosuhteita, ja sitä kautta nurmikkohan voi parhaiten silloin, ku sitä lannotetaan.
Ja mitä minä oon pannu merkille, ihan niinku nurmialueiden kuntoakin katsellessa, että kaupunki ei hirveesti panosta tohon nurmialueiden ja puistojen lannottamiseen.
Ni sitä kautta mun mielestä voitais kaikki osallistua, ja kaikki koirat, koska koiran sitä kahdella loistavaa lannotetta, nii, kaikki koirat sinne puistikoihin, ja ei kerätä niitä niihin pusseihin, jotka kuorvittaa luontoa.
Ni sitä kautta kannataan kortema kekoa tähän, surmialueiden lannotusasiaa.
Tämmöse idea heitä, ilmaise, ei muutaku, hyvää kevättä kaikille, tosikoille ja veikikoille.
Kohta jatketaan saman aihellaarin kimpussa, ennen puheluita, sähköposti vähän eri teemasta, siinä lukee näin:
Olenko ainoa pilkuttaja, joka on pannut merkille, miten tiedotusvälineissä haastattelija kiittää haastateltavaa, ja haastateltava kiittää takaisin?
Eikö suomalaisempi tapa vastata olisi, ole hyvä, olkaa hyvä.
Kiitos, on Amerikasta levinnyt tapa, joka on rantautunut myös meille, ja särähtää pilkuttajan korvaan ikävästi.
Vähän löylyä lisää, kun haastateltava vastaa, ole hyvä, voisi haastattelija vastata, yritän olla.
Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jossa ei ole mitään nimeä mukana.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
No, tässä Risto puustilee Peräpunavuoresta, ei.
Hei, hei.
Mä oon näkövammainen, tästä Helsingin kaupungin jutusaitetta, ollaan poistamassa esineetsinä painikenappi, niinku siitä, että pääset ylistämään tietoa, kerraki, jos olis äänimerkki.
Ni, liikennevaloista.
Ni, ja niitä on aika harvassa. Ja kun kattoo ydinkeskustaa, niissä on liikennevaloista, aika harvassa on, mutta äänimerkki toimii, tai toimii.
Se on tota, jos kattoo niinku suoraan, jos Suomen pääkatu, elikä Mannerheimen tienii, lastipalatsin kohdalla kunnan äänimärkit, mut siitä ratikkapisakin toisella puolella, niinku foorimen kulmassa, ei toimi äänimärkki.
Pulevardilla ei toimi äänimärkki, ei toimi, monesta kohtaa keskellä kaupunki ei toimi äänimärkit.
Ja, mulla on periaatteessa peräpunavuoresta, kamppi on neljä valoristeista, jossa on punaiset ja vihreet valot, et mä ennen erota niitä.
Tosisaal, pitää niinku vaan mennä sattumaan mukaisesti niistä yli, onneks nii vähän onneks, tai sitten voi aina seurataa ihmisiä, jotka ku käy päin punaisia.
Eli vahva toiveisi on, että liikennevalojen äänimärkit pitäisi hoitaa kuntoon.
Kyllä, jos on Suomen pääkaupunkia, keskustassa ei toimi tällaista asiaa, nii… ja sitä mietitää vielä, että ne painikemerkit,
joissa on niinkuin, esimerkiksi Itäkeskustan läylä, Itäkeskuksen metroasemaa, ku on sille väylälle kohti Iiriskeskusta,
on esimerkiksi sellaiset, että painät, että pääset ylittämään, nii, ne tullaan poistamaan, sellaiset, nää painikenapit.
Nii, mitä se toimii jatkossa sitten?
Ku siinä koetikin niinku sen verran vähemmän niistä jalakulkijoita siinä kiesinä,
sinä metrasemata sen väylä ylisinä kohti Iiriskeskusta, Itäkeskuksa, nii,
nii, miten tällaiset asiat toimii sitten jatkossa?
Mutta niinku tosiaan niinku se pääasia, ni se, että, että, jos on valot ylipäätä,
nii pitäis olla myös äänimärkitkin.
Kiitoksia, paljon tästä soitosta ja mukavaa asunontajatkoa.
No nii, kiitos, moi moi.
Niä ideä tulevaisuutta varten.
Pitäis verrastaa puutarhoja enemmän omakotitalotonteille,
kasvattaa omeniasiat ja omenahilloja, kesäaikää syötävän erilaisia omenalaatuja,
ja myös marjapensaita, punaista viinimarjaa, mustaviinimarjaa,
ja sitten karviäisiä ja muita erilaisia helemäpuita.
Ja samaten myös voistuvataan niistä siitä saa talvesta syötävää ja juotävää,
ja mehuja ja kaikkea, ja muita tällaisia.
Suomen kansa on unastut tämän vanhan hyvän tämän kokonaan pois.
Omenah puut voi peittää puutarhoja kurkeilla tuomisillaan verkoillaan,
ja myydään tuomisia verkoja tuomisillaan metallialan myyntiliikkeessä,
jossa on semmoista, se on tätä petoiniverkkoa, puutarhoja kurkeillaan,
ei päästä tuolta jänikset syömään niitä.
Ja sen takia on tärkeää, että myös kunnissa olisi,
ja kaupungissa olisi puutarhan palstoja,
ja joka kaupungissa,
että ihmiset voisivat harrastaa ulkonaan liikkumista,
ja ulkotyöskentelyä.
Putarhan hoitoa myös, se on fyysistä,
se on mielenterveydestä, se on terveydestä,
se on hapeensäänille hyvä,
ja paljon muuta, luonnonmukaista toimittää enemmän,
ihmisten parhaaksi.
No, iltapäivä.
Mä ihmettelen, ku tässä just äsken soitti kansaradio,
yks mies, joka kehuu Staran hoitamia kattuja tänä talvena,
ni olisi kiva tietää, mistäköhä päihän soitti Helsingistä ilmeisesti,
ku Staran hoitaa, kai vaan Helsingistä,
mut kyl mä sanoo ainakin,
että minun mielestä ei oo nii paljon taas vaihteet,
nyt löytää oli teräjälkeet,
ei oo kyllä hyvin hoidettu, päivä jatkoa.
Siinä soittaja pääsikin edellisen jakson kommentoinnin pariin.
Seuraavaksi lisää puheluita, joissa otetaan kantaa aiempien ohjelmien sisältöihin.
Sitä puhelupakettia edeltää yksi viesti,
joka on lähetetty kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
No tupakat ei saa näkyä,
niin miksi kaljat, lonksut, sidukat ynnä muut
ovat reilusti kaupoissa esillä,
onko tupakat vaarallisempia,
esimerkiksi niille, jotka yrittää päästä eroon alkosta?
Pitäis olla suojaseinä alue alkojuomille.
Tämä teksti oli lähetetty kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Sen oli kirjoittanut nimimerkki Saku.
Päivää, päivää.
Tuossa, kun kuuntelin sen kansaradionin,
siellä yhdellä naisella oli hyvä kysymys,
niin mulla oli siihen vastaus.
Kerro.
Se sanoi siihen aineen,
että mitä vasten miehiltä tukka lähtee,
ja naisilta ei lähe.
Niin, kaljuuntuminen, joo.
Ni, joo.
Ni, vastaus on siihen,
että tyhjä lato ei kattoa tarvitsee.
No nii.
Joo, tämmönen on aika hyvää vastaus monella.
Selvä juttu, kiitoksia paljon tästä.
Palei hyvä, hei, hei.
Hei, hei.
No, se ois kinhet skäritelt parasyot morjestaa.
Tässä kuunneltii teidän tota yöohjelmaa,
ja severta oli noita, muun muassa,
vegetarian hernekkeettä, soppasyöjiä ja sun muitani.
Kylähän se vaan niin on se asia,
että kyllä terveen suomalaisen miehen ja naisen pitää
vähintään syödä viikossa kaks kiloa,
naudan jauhe lihaa, höystettynä kermalla ja voilla.
Et, jos sitä ei syä, niin on pikkuisen päästään kajahtanut,
eikä ymmärrä oman kansantalouden, eikä huoltovarmuuden,
eikä puhtaan suomalaisen ruoan puolesta yhtään mitään.
Puumattakaan punaisesta maidosta, tai tankkimaidosta,
mitä hyvin valituista ruokakaupoista saa.
Ja, no, siis ihan ihme volhottajia löytyy kyllä tähän linjaan,
ja toivon, että jokainen nyt kuuntelee
ja menee huomenna kauppaan ostamaan,
naudan jauhe lihaa ja punaista maitoa.
Morjes.
Terveys, tässä on Lille.
Joku vaati siellä kansanradiossa,
että kansanedustajien lukumäärä täytyisi laskea viiteenkömmene.
No, minäpä ajankuluksetossa räknäsin,
että miltä se eduskunta silloin näyttäisi.
Näyttäisi esimerkiksi siltä,
että Hämestä tulisi neljä kansanedustajaa,
Savokarilasta neljä, Vaasasta neljä,
Keski-Suomesta kolme, Lapista yks.
Eli aina aika ison alueen vastuunin olisi aika harvalla ihmisellä.
Se tarkoittais myös sitä,
että vaalipiirestä, niin käytännössä katsoen,
aina tulis valituksi suurimman puoluen kaks ehdokasta
ja muitten puoluetta yks ehdokasta.
Tämmösen pienentyi eduskunnan puoluejakauma
tällä nykysellä vaalisysteemillä,
elikkä korkei vertailuluku,
niin sillä päästää sitten aina eduskuntaa järjestyksessä,
niin olis suunnilleen niin,
että perussuomalaiset viistoista paikkaa,
kokoomus kolmatoista paikkaa,
STP kaks toista paikkaa.
Sitten nämä pienemmät,
keskusta kuus, RKP kaks,
vihreät kaks, vasemmasta liitto kaks.
Tarkoittais siis sitä,
että noista kolmesta suurista puolueista,
ni aina kaks pitäis valita,
ja sitten elle kelpais mikä tahansa
sitä muu puoluet tuki puolueeksi.
Eli meille tulisi tällaiset hallitukset.
Sitä itse kukin miettii,
että olisiko se hyvä vai huono asia.
Siinä Lille kuljetti meidät kotimaan kysymysten ääresten.
No, Pohjanmaan okko täältä.
Tätä velkajarrua on ihmetellyt,
että mitä järkiä tässä on,
asettajarru juuri nyt,
kun velka on aivan tapissa.
Tiedän kyllä paljon politiikkaa seuranneena,
että tämä on oikeistostaktinen siirto.
Tällä siirrolla estetään loivempi velan,
tasapainoitus,
ja leikkaukset jatkuvat myös seuraavassa hallituksessa.
Tämä velkajarru olisi pitänyt tehdä jo viistosta vuotta sitten.
Yleensä jarrua painotahan ennen kolaria.
Ei hyärytä painaa, jos oi jo kolissut.
Ja vanha sanonta sanoo,
että ei kannata pyllistää,
jos oi jo paskat housuus.
Ja näille, jotka o hoitanu maan talouden tällaisen kuntoon,
tekisi mieleni sanoa,
kun Kekkonen aikoinaan hallitukselle,
että "saatanan tunarit".
Nyt on aika punnita sanat ja teot,
onko lait ja määräykset,
samanlaisia kaikille nimittäin.
Tietääkseni Suomessa on käytäntö,
että teknisillä laitteilla ei tehdä kauppaa sotakäyvien maiden kanssa.
Ja tällä hetkellä USA on sotakäyvä maa,
ei sitä pääse mihinkään yli,
eikä ympäri,
on riehu ympäri maapalloa.
Niin, mites tämä jäämurtajakauppa?
Voidaanko se nyt tehdä tässä tilanteessa?
Vai, onko se raa, joka tässä ratkaisee?
On meinaa aika isoista raalista kysymys.
Tämmösiä tässä tuumalee, veka, pälkänelta.
Tässä haudan partailla oleva partamoosis.
Tuossa äsken korkkasi hernetrittoportia,
jatkoi vedellä.
Olii muutama sattumakin vettötiä,
hanavettä ryypiin, tyytypojaksi.
Minä eläkeukko kiitaharitusta, kun ei tarttei ruokalistoja miettiä.
Ei leppoa ja halapa, ei nauda lihaa,
muille kuin herroille,
vähempi arvostotta kosasta ta sikaa.
Minäkin niin kiitollinen ollen, kun terveyden hoitoki onnistuu aina.
Ota porana, vaivakuu vaivaa.
Huomenna lähevaltiomme tästä hakemaan puutajahla tässä arkua rapitelemaan.
Ei tule yksi eläjähautaus nii kalliissikunnalle.
Et tästä viimeistä matkaa odotellessa.
Suurtyytoshallitukselle.
Ni hei.
Näiden kiitosten jälkeen on luontevaa siirtyä kuuntelemaan tämänkertainen annos sote-teemaisia puheluita.
Aloitamme aiheen WhatsApp-viestillä, jossa lukee näin:
Hei, K.R. porukat.
Haluan kiittää Sanikran laasosta yli 65-vuotiaiden kokeilusta.
Olen käynyt Oulussa yksityisellä lääkärillä ja saanut todella hyvää palvelua ja sain hyvän suunnitelman jatkoon.
Kiitän ja toivon, että tämä jatkuu, esimerkiksi kolme kertaa vuodessa, voisi käydä tämänkaltaisen toiminnan puitteissa lääkärissä.
Suuri kiitos, kevättä odotellessa.
Tämän viestin oli meille lähettänyt WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta, niymerkki, kannatti kokeilla.
Meille Kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä, sekä tällaisia tekstimuotoisia kommentteja, että myös ääniviestejä.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 54 64.
No, Markkuli, terve.
Terve, terve.
Eikö, mä olin tossa joului äitilä, ku se oo vähän huonoskunnus.
Mä oon ite 66-vuotias.
Sille nyt tuli nää digitaaliporuka, tai nää, ranneket ja näin, mut se ei saanu mitä ohjeita.
Siiis joku tämmönen turvaranneket tyyppinen.
Joo, ku sillä käy se, ajattelee, siellä yksikympisellä muijallekki pitäis jotakin neuvoisee, et miten ne toi.
Mutta mitä ei neuvottu?
Ei, ja sitten ku mä oli siinä, ja mun sisko ja mun veli oli siinä.
No, mä sano, no, mä luo, tökseli seinää ja painoo sitä.
Kyl asianut joku vasta.
No, miten kävi?
Ni, sit nii, nii, tätä ei oka päivitetty tänne ollenka.
Meinää just lehdestä, ku luit katakuu, joku yksitoist kertaa painanu, ja niihku.
No, selviskö se teidän kohdalla asia?
Joo, nytä se on sitten nii hyvin innostunut, ja ku oppinu sitä käyttää, että.
Joo.
Mut se, et ku sitä pitäis saata sitä niiku käyttöohjeita, niiku tietät.
Ja se on nyt näköjää täällä niiku Tuuslasjärven pääsittualle nii.
Siis ne voimoni unohtuu niiku kokonaan.
Joo, mutta hienoa, ku sinä nostit tämän asian esille, toivottavasti jatkossa sujuu paremmin.
Joo, kiirti, moi.
Hei vaan, kaikki kansasarion kuuntelijat.
Olen aika älistynyt, seurasin tässä televisiosta.
Vammaisilta lapsilta.
Otetaan rahat pois minne kashe on päässyt.
Hiukan liikkumaan, eikö mitään muuta mahdollisuutta ole.
Jos ei oo vanhukset tai lapset, ni sit on tällaiset vammaiset.
Eruskunta saisi hävetä.
Siellä on puoli, tyhjä sali aina, ja torstaisin, kun katsomme sitä.
Raat pois heiltä, ja antakaan niille, jotka tarvitsee.
Hyä päivänjatkoa kaikille kansalaisille, hei, hei.
No voi ha vitalis, rikosten tekijöillä on ilmaista täysihoitoa.
Heidän terveyden hoidon riittämättömyydestä ollaan huolissaan, kun samanaikaisesti suljetaan vuodeosastoja, ja elätetään maahanmuuttajia.
Että, onpa hyvin asiat tässä Suomen tasavallassa, vai onko tää minkälainen tasavallassa?
Ei muuta ku kaikkea hyvää, koitetaan jaksaa, tavallinen kansa.
Moikka.
Ja kun on alkuun päästy, niin antaa mennä vaan, kuten aikoinaan Vexi kirjoitti, tai siis Emil Retee, eli sote-aiheen parissa riittää vielä kommentoitavaa.
Enen äänimuotoisia ajatuksia tämä kirje, ärsyttää.
Onko näillä naisilla huono muisti, kun monta kertaa illassa mainostavat emätin ja vakinakuivuutta?
Voisitteko mennä muistitestiin?
Jos alapää kuivuu, niin jokainen osaa sitä hoitaa, tai mennä lääkäriin.
Täällättä voin lukea kirjeessä, joka on saapullut meille, kansaradioon ilman nimeä.
Meille voi laittää korttea ja muuta perinteistä postiosoitteeseen, kansanradio, PL 79, 00, 24, Yleisradio.
Tässä yksi mummo, liiki yhdeksänkympinen.
Tässä yksin ollessaan jo en mietiskellyt tätä alkoholin kotien kulitusta.
Se on ihan selvästi osa soteuudistosta.
Kun nyt nämä hoivaa vailla olevat vanhukset voisivat tilata alkuntuotteita helposti kotiin,
Eikä edes iän määrittely olisi mitenkään vaikeata, niin ei varmaan hirveän pitkiä aikoja kuluisi, kun jo vanhusten määrä alkaisi totaalisesti pudota, eikä hoitapaikoista sen jälkeen olisi mitään pulaa. Kiitaksa.
Olami soittaa hyvää päivää, pari sanaa omaishoidosta.
Omaishoito on päivän sana, se on muodikas, frendikäs, se on hoitoa kodin omaista, näin hän päättäjät vakuuttaa.
Vaan kun monikin omaishoitaja on jo itsekin väsynyt, ikääntynyt, ehkä itsekin hoitoa vaille, se on vanhusten säilentää.
Pois silmistä, ehkä ajatellaan niin. Kyllä sivistysvaltiossa tulee julkinen hoitopaikka olla, jokaiselle ken tarvitsee, sen he ovat työllään ansaaneet.
Onhan häpeä, ettemme toimi niin. Vuoro tulee kullekin ajallaan. Hyvää keväntä, terveisin olami.
No hei, kävinpä Essoten emänöimässä ryhmäkodissa, jota pari vuosikymmentä sitten olisi sanottu vanhäkodiksi.
Sinä päivänä siellä oli seuraavanlainen möny, aamiaiseksi kaurapuuro, lounaaksi riisipuuro, veteen keitittynä ystävälleni, koska hän on maitoalergikko ja luomaksilla mukilinen vettä, päiväliseksi mannavelli.
Onkohan tämän mönyn laatinut oikein geriatrisen ravitsemustieteeseen, vartta vasten erikoistunut ravitsemusterapia?
Pytä ruokahan huokait, hei, hei.
Se on pitkän ammattikokemuksen omava sote-ammattiläinen tätä Rovaniemöta, hei.
Ihmettelen vaan sitä, että nykyäänkin on tällaista hierarkkista työpaikkoja, jähmeyttä ja suoranoista ehkä työpaikkakiusaamistakin.
Itselläni on aika pitkä kokemus tukipalveluista, ja olen ollut monenlaisessa työpaikossa, niin tällaiset epäviralliset käytänteet työpaikoilla, niin ne kyllä minua pistää suoruttamaan.
Kyllä, jos on jotain jostain sovittu, niin kyllä se pitäisi pitää kiinni, ja sitten ei kun luistaa sillain niistä asioista.
Monesti sote-alalla näkee nykyäänkin tällaisia epävirallisia käytänteitä, ja ne pistää kyllä mietityttämään, että miten voi olla, että olen ollut monenlaisessa sote-alapaikoissa.
Ihmetyttää kyllä ja ammattiryhmien välillä on tätä skismaa. Joillakin toimii paremmi, ja joillakin huonommi, mutta tässä tapauksessa negatiilisesti itse yllätyn, että kuinka huonosti tukipalvelutyöntekijöitä kohdellaan. Työpaiko.
Katsaus.Puheluita edeltää, sähköposti.
Olympialaiset tuli ja meni, kritiikkiä on aiheuttanut sanan lausuminen. Ihan sama meitsille, mutta haluan kiittää yleä, hyvästä kattauksesta.
Erikois kiitos lätkän kommentaattoreille, kojolle ja jusalle. Rauhallista faktaa todellisilta ammattilaisilta, ei mitään ylimääräistä huutoa tai hehkutusta.
Tämän sähköpostin meille oli kirjoittanut nimerkki Lexa.
Kiitos, hei hei.
No morjesta, mulla kävi tämmönen ajatus, että talvi olympialaisista voitais peruuttaa hiihto, että tämän sijasta me voitais kirjoittaa vaikka no kahdenkymmenen norjalaisten nimi paperille, pistää nää paperit lappuja, sitten vaikka olympiakometia jäsen voisi valita sieltä kolme norjalaista.
Ja sitten nämä kolme norjalaista on sitten kultamitallisti, opeamitallisti ja pronssimitallisti. Tällä tavalla me säästettäis aikaa, ja voitais vaikka luoda uusia lajeja, koska lopputulos on kuitenkin sama. Jees, palaillaan, mo.
Ei voi muuta kuin nauraattale suomalaisten hiihdolleetelle selittelelle. Iivo Niskänen jo oli mukaa kipiä, ku lähti ja keskeittiä.
Näällä jatkuesti jotakin vaivoja, ku ne eivät pärijää, ni selittelee ja selittelee ja selittelee.
Kyläkään ne pitää sitä jotää, vaan naurattaa meitä kansalaisia, ku ei ne mä hyvät oo koskaan kipiänä, eikä niitä, niitä ei tarvitse selitellä, ku teik lähteä polusruimita.
Soumalaan ne aina selittelee. Ja sää varmaa voi olla tässä selittelyssä myös takana, ku eduskunta vaalitha nyt vähän oli vuoden päässä, ni sinähän hyvää kansalaisesta ja aineesta.
Näässä nääs nii saatossa urheilijoissamme, koska sää jo sen selittelyä, se pittelyyn taidoossa, vaan jo.
Tää saati käsitti, jos pääsee eduskuntais, ei muuta, kiitoksia, hei.
Lähtee mä jokka tää Turusta, vaan hei. Muuttamaan sanaa vielä noista olympialaisista.
Ensinkin, Itäleilaisista oli tosi hyvin järjestänyt. Kaikki lait, aikataulut piti, ja se, mikä oli hienoa, et katsovat oli täynnä, ja niinen kannusti aina oli sitten, minkä maalainen tahansa, kenellä oli hyvä suoritus.
Ja sit se, mistä mä nautin komana penkpyrheena, oli semmoisia uusia lajeja, mitä yleensä ei näe normaalisti.
Suomessa aika harvoin, kurlinki oli tosi kivaa kattoo, ja sit siinä oli se asiantuntija, mikä hyvin selvitti aina, mitä niinku kannattais tehdä.
Samoin mä katsoin kelkkailuja, näitä hyppyjä, tota noin. Ja tietysti ampuvaihitto oli yhkaslai.
Ja sitten jääkiekko, ku se kaveri sanoi viime sunutaan kansanrariossa, et oli surkeet tuomarit jääkökossa, se ei nyt ihan pidä paikkas, koska.
Jokaisen maan valmentijat ja johtajat sarottavi tosi hyvät tuomarit, et NHL:n ammattituomarit, ne on nii, nii kova ammattitaito, eikä ne veränmienkä kotiin päin.
Se oli sillä ihan hyvin, et oli ihan mukava, kaks viikkoa.
Ymmärsin erittäin hyvin, ku tulee semmosia tärkeitä lajaisilla, ku tulee kansanrariossa onnuntana.
Tottakai, oluppelasto on kerran neljesvuores, ne pitää olla ykkös aihe, ei muuta ku hyvä talven jatkoo, moi.
Siinä päästiin haastatteluihin, näinpä nyt onkin luontevaa siirtyä radio- ja televisioasioita koskeviin ajatuksiin.
Ennen puheluita kerron, että kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantai kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta, ja tilaat ohelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, nii saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Hei, tarjo, Suomesta tuli sinkku irta, nii tuli mieleen, että, voi mitä kaikkee sinkut on nähny, ja kuullu, ja vallankin nähny, piste, piste, piste, moi.
No, minulla ei oo oikeasta varsinaista nimeä ollenkaan, mutta minä nyt vähän kiukkuani purkaan, ku ainoa kanava, mihin voi purkaa kiukkua.
Kato ku, muistojen pulevaadi, on ainoa, mistä tulee jotain aikuisten ihmisten musiikkiä ilman mainoksia.
No, nyt sinne on ku tullu joku keskustelupalsta, pikkuisen musiikkiä välillä ja taas keskustella.
Et, mutta kun mä en tiedä, mihin mä soittaisi, mä soiti, mutta ku sinne pitää painaa nappia sinne ja tänne, ja mä olen, aivan, kato, eihän ihminen ehdi aamulla istua, ja kuunnella, et mitä nyt tulee, ja mistä te puhutte, vaan haluais musiikkiä, ja kiitos kuuntelemisesta, ku mun harmitaku.
Mä olen niin tottunut vuosien saatossa sitä kuuntelun, ja nyt siellä vaan jutellaan, ku, syvän päivän jatkoa.
Joo, se meni taas lauantai aamupäivä tilalle, ku ootettii, että alkaa luomen eri alueiden alueuutiset TV1, niin olikohan näin, että taas meni sotahullu amerikkalainen pommittamaan sinne Iranii, ja
Sitä sitten kommentoidaan ja vatuloidaan radiosta sekä televisiosta, eikä oisi riittänyt, että se ois radiossa tätä kommentoitu, eikä mennä niitä alueuutisten päälle, että onko ne Suomen uutiset niin epätärkeitä, että niitä ei voi näyttää koko kansalle, että niitä pitää sitten kaivaa jostakin Yleareenasta, eikö näitä kommentaattoria, jalla on palakka kymmeniä tuhansia kuukalais, eikö sitä voi muuta näyttää?
Nimimerkki Mummo, entinen Pohjois-Karjela radiopaikalle, kiitos.
Ja kuten Pauli kertoi, niin ainakin kalenterin mukaan, kevät on alkanut.
Sispa on paikallaan kuulla Aalonlassen kevätruno.
Mutta kerron vielä kansarion puhelinnumeron sitä ennen, se on nolla kahdeksan, nolla nolla, yksi viisi neljä, kuusi neljä, ja puhelu on soitteelle maksuton, ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen, tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Ei, tää naalolla se, kaksi tärkeintä, aulinko ja mesisade, sen tekee, lumikinukset valuu jo veteen, purot myös mukavasti solisee, kohta varmaan iäkka pölisee.
No mitähän vielä muuta, alkaa olla, aika vaistaa suuta, rakkaus useampia kiinnostaa, sitä toivotaan, mitä halutaan, kevää merkkejä seurataan, muuttolinnuista jutellaan, meidän aarteista pidetään, yhdessä hyvin eletään.
Sitten värit kauneuden takaa, upea vihreä, luonto jakaa, isot puut kaupungin kaunistaa, mukat lisää, kauneus huipustaa.
Jos sinivuokon lähdä saa, hyvän mielen jo siitä saa. Nyt tarvi unesta herään, hyvän mielen hetkiä, koko kevään kerää.
Suosittelen samaa teille toisillekin, että semmoista kevään arkoa tässä toivotaan, ja kiitos, heipä, hei.
Vielä on ainakin aikaa mennä alapesulle, ennen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää, ja erityisesti nyt kansainvälisen naisten päivän hengessä, kaikille naisille.
Koiviston Louri kiittää ja kumartaa. Kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
Mummo täällä soittelee. No, alapesuu suihkutkoa vessassani, joskus on nii lyhyt se, hukki siinä, että se ei yllää, ees sinne pyttyy.
Ja, eihä se nyt lattialle voi pylyä se pestä. Kiitos.
Se oi jokisamppa tässä. Mieti vaan tuomosta asiatta, ku kaikki on somessa. Ja minäkin oon somessa, nii mä mietin vaan, että tapaako kuka enää kasvoi.
Liveenä ketää. Onko kaikki tuolla somessa tapahtuvaa? Toivottavasti vielä enemmän tapattais liveenä. Ei mulla muuta.
Laihialais, miksi? Miks Laihialais mies ostaa norjalaiset sukset? Tietysti sen takia, että niillä pääsee paljon komempaan.
Suomalaisilla suksilla, mutta ei mul muuta. Hei.